welcome can I turn this on baby all
right hit people here can you guys hear
me is the mic on no maybe you can ask
them to turn it on maybe we can get a
big there we go alright maybe we can get
a bigger auditorium we'll see so welcome
to CS 183 B I'm Sam Altman I'm the
president of Y Combinator
nine years ago I was a Stanford student
and then I dropped that start a company
and I've been an investor for the last
few so YC we've been teaching people how
to start startups for nine years most of
it's very hands-on and specific to the
startups what thirty percent of it is
pretty generally applicable and so we
think that we can teach that thirty
percent in this class and even though
that's only thirty percent of the way
there
hopefully it'll still be really helpful
we've taught a lot of its at YC already
but it's all been off the record and
this is the first time that a lot of
what we teach in life you can be on the
record so we've invited some of our best
speakers to come and give the same talks
to give it YC we've now funded seven
hundred and twenty companies and so
we're pretty sure that a lot of this
advice is pretty good
we can't fund every startup yet but we
can't hopefully make this advice very
generally available guest speakers are
going to teach 17 of the 20 classes I'm
only teaching three County and YC itself
every guest speaker has been involved in
the creation of a billion plus dollar
company so the advice should be that
theoretical it's all been it's all from
people who have done all the advice in
this class is geared towards people
starting a business where the goal is
hyper growth and eventually building a
very large company much of it doesn't
apply in other cases and I want to want
people up front that if you try and do
these things and a lot of big companies
or non startups it won't work it should
still be interesting I really do think
that startups through the way of the
future and if worth trying to understand
them but startups are very different
than normal companies so over the course
of today and Thursday I'm going to try
to give an overview of the four areas
that you need to excel at in order to
maximize your chances of success to
startup and then throughout the course
the guest speakers are going to drill
into all of these in more detail so the
four areas you need a great idea
a great product a great team great
execution these overlaps somewhat but
I'm going to have to talk about them
somewhat individually to make it make
sense you may still fail the outcome is
something like ideas times product times
execution times teen times luck where
luck is a random number between zero and
ten thousand literally that much but if
you do really well in the foyer you can
control you have a good chance at it we
sell amount of success one of the
exciting things about startups is that
they are surprisingly even playing field
young inexperienced you can do this old
and very experienced you can do this too
and one of the things that I
particularly like about startups is that
some of the things that are bad in other
work situations like being poor and
unknown are actually huge assets when it
comes to starting a startup Before we
jump in on the how I want to talk about
why you should start a startup I'm
somewhat hesitant to be doing this class
at all because you should never start a
startup just for the sake of doing so
there must either ways to get rich and
everyone who starts the startup always
says always that they couldn't have
imagined how hard and painful is going
to be you should only start a startup
that you can feel compelled by a
particular problem and that you think
starting the company is the best way to
solve it
the specific passion should come first
and the startup second in fact all of
the big successes we have at YC followed
this so for the second half of today's
lecture Dustin Moskovitz the co-founder
of Facebook and asana is going to take
over and talk about why to start a
startup we're so surprised by the amount
of attention that's cost got it we're
going to make sure we spend a lot of
time on the why okay so the first of the
four areas a great idea it's become
popular in recent years to say that the
idea doesn't matter in fact it's almost
uncool to spend a lot of time thinking
about the idea for a startup you're just
supposed to start third stuff at the
wall see what sticks and not even spend
any time thinking about if it'll be
valuable if it works and pivots are
supposed to be great the more said it's
the better so this is totally wrong
things do evolve in ways that are
difficult to predict and there's a limit
to how much you can figure out without
actually getting a product my hands of
users and great execution is at least 10
times more important and a hundred times
harder than a good idea but the pendulum
is a long way out
lack here a bad idea is still bad in the
pivot happy world that wearing today
feels really suboptimal great execution
towards a terrible idea will get you
nowhere there are exceptions of course
but most great companies start with a
great idea not a pivot if you look at
successful pivots they almost always are
a pivot into something the founders
themselves wanted not a random made-up
idea
Airbnb happened because Brian Chesky
couldn't pay his rent but he did have
some extra space in general though if
you look at the track record of pivots
they don't become big companies I myself
used to believe ideas didn't matter that
much but I'm very sure that's wrong now
the definition of the idea is we talk
about it is very broad it includes the
size and the growth of the market the
growth strategy for the company
the defensibility strategy and so on
when you're evaluating an idea you need
to think through all these things not
just the product if it works out you're
going to be working on this for 10 years
so it's worth some real upfront time to
think there's a long term value in the
defense ability of the business even
though plans themselves are worthless
the exercise of planning is really
valuable and totally missing in most
startups today long-term thinking is so
rare anywhere but especially in startups
that is a huge advantage if you do it
remember that the idea will expand you
become more ambitious as you go you
certainly don't need to have everything
figured out in a path from here to world
domination but you really want a nice
kernel to start with he wants me to can
develop in interesting ways
as you're thinking through ideas another
thing that we see young founders get
wrong all the time is that someday you
need to build a business that's
difficult to replicate this is an
important part of a good idea I want to
make this point again because it's so
important the idea should come first
the startups should come second wait to
start a startup until you come up with
an idea you feel compelled to explore
this is also the way to choose between
multiple ideas if you have several ideas
that all seem pretty good work on the
one that you think about most often when
you're not trying to think about work
but we hear again and again from
founders that they wish they have waited
started startup until they came up with
an idea they really loved
another way of looking at this is that
the best companies are almost always
mission oriented it's difficult to get
large groups of people to the extreme
levels of focus and productivity that
you need first started to be successful
unless the company feels like an
important mission and it's usually
really hard to get that without a great
sounding idea
a related advantage of mission oriented
ideas is that you yourself will be
dedicated to them it takes years and
years usually a decade to create a great
startup if you don't love and believe in
what you're building you'll likely to
give up at some point along the way
there's no way I know of to get through
the pain of a start-up without belief
that the mission really matters a lot of
founders especially students believe
that their startups only going to take
two or three years and then after that
they'll work on what they're really
passionate about that almost never works
good startups usually take 10 years a
third advantage of mission oriented
companies is the people outside the
company are more willing to help you
you'll get more support on a hard
important project than a derivative one
when it comes to starting startups in
many ways it's easier to start a hard
startup and easy startup this is one of
those counterintuitive things it takes
people a long time to understand it's
difficult to overstate how important the
mission driven is someone emphasized it
one last time derivative companies
companies that copy an existing idea
with very few new insights don't excite
people and they don't compel the team to
work hard enough to be successful Paul
Graham is going to talk about how to get
startup ideas next week it's something
that a lot of founders struggle with but
it's something I believe you can get
better with it better out with practice
and it's definitely worth trying to get
better at the hardest part about coming
up with great ideas is that the best
ideas often look terrible at the
beginning the 13th search engine and
without all the features of a web portal
most people thought that was pointless
search was done and anyway it didn't
matter that much portal 4 where the
value of that the 10th social network
and limited only to college students
with no money also terrible my face at
one and who wants college students with
customers or way to stay on strangers
couches that just sounds terrible all
around these all sounded really bad but
they turned out to be good if they'd not
be really good there would have been too
many people working on them
it's Peter Thiel's in a discussion to
this class you want an idea that turns
into a monopoly but you can't get a
monopoly in a big market right away too
much competition for that you have to
find a small market in which you can get
a monopoly and then quickly expand this
is why some great startup ideas look
really bad at the beginning it's good if
you can say something like today only
the small subset of users are going to
use my product but I'm gonna get all of
them and in the future almost everyone
will use my product here's the theme
that's going to come up a lot you need
conviction in your own belief and a
willingness to ignore others may saying
the hard part is that this is a very
fine line there's right on one side of
it and crazy on the other but keep in
mind if you did come up with a great
idea most of you are going to think it's
bad you should be happy about that
means they won't compete with you this
is also a reason why it's not usually
dangerous to tell people about your idea
the truly good ideas don't sound like
they're worth stealing you want an idea
about what you can say I know it sounds
like a bad idea but here specifically
why it's actually a great one you want
to sound crazy but you want to actually
be right and you want an idea that not
many other people are working on and
it's okay if it doesn't sound big at
first common mistake among founders
especially first-time founders is they
think that the first version of their
product the first version of their idea
needs to sound really big but it doesn't
it needs to take over a small specific
market and expand from there that's how
most great companies have started
unpopular but right that's what you're
going for you want something that sounds
like a bad idea that is a good idea you
also really want to take the time to
think about how the market is going to
evolve you need a market that's going to
be big in ten years most investors are
obsessed with the market sites today and
they don't think it all about how the
market is going to evolve in fact I
think this is one of the biggest
systemic mistakes that investors make
they think about the growth of the
startup itself they don't think about
the growth of the market I care much
more about the growth rate of the market
than its current size and I also care if
there's any reason that's going to top
out you should think about this I prefer
to invest in the company that's going
after a small but rapidly growing market
then a big blip slow growing one one of
the big advantages of these sort
markets these small the rapidly growing
markets is that customers are usually
pretty desperate for a solution and
they'll put up with an imperfect but
rapidly improving product and a big
advantage of being the student one of
the two biggest advantages is that you
probably have better intuition about
which markets are likely to start
growing rapidly than older people do
another thing that students usually
don't understand at least takes a while
you cannot create a market that doesn't
want to exist you can basically change
everything in a startup but the market
so you should actually do some thinking
to be sure or at least assure as you can
be if the market you're going after is
going to grow and be there there are a
lot of different ways to talk about the
right kind of market for example
searching someone else's wave or
stepping into an up elevator or being
part of a movement but all of this is
just a way of saying you want to market
it's going to grow really quickly it may
seem small today it may be small today
but you know and other people don't that
it's going to grow really fast so think
about where this is happening the world
you need to sort of a tail end to make a
startup successful the exciting thing is
there are probably more of these talons
now than ever before as Marc Andreessen
said Socrates in the world it's just
everywhere there like so many great
ideas out there and you just pick one
and find one that you really care about
another version of this it was founded
the same idea it sequoias famous
question why not why is this the perfect
time for this particular idea and to
start this particular company why
couldn't it have been done two years ago
and why was two years in the future be
too late for the most successful
startups we've been involved with
they've all had a great idea great
answer to this question and if you don't
you should be at least somewhat
suspicious about it in general it's best
if you're building something that you
yourself need you'll understand it much
better than if you have to understand it
by talking to a customer to build a very
first version if you don't eat it
yourself and you're building something
that someone else needs realize that
you're at a big disadvantage and get
very very close to your customers try to
work in their office if you can and if
not talk to them multiple times a day
another somewhat counterintuitive thing
about good startup ideas is that they're
almost always very easy to explain and
very easy to understand if it takes more
than a sentence to explain what you're
doing
it's almost always a sign that it's too
complicated it should be a clearly
articulate articulated vision with a
small number of words and the best ideas
are usually either very different from
existing companies in one important way
like Google being a search engine that
work just really well and none of the
other stuff of the portals or totally
new like SpaceX any companies it's a
clone of something else that already
exists with some small or made-up
differentiator like we're going to be X
beautiful design or we're going to be y
for people that like red wine instead
that usually fails so as I mentioned one
of the great things about being a
student is that you have a very good
perspective on new technology and
learning to get good at having new ideas
takes a while so start working on that
right now
that's one thing we hear from people all
the time that they wish they've done
more when they were student the other is
meeting potential co-founders you have
no idea how good in an environment
you're right now for meeting people that
you can start a company with down the
road and the one thing that we always
tell college students is more important
than starting any particular startup is
giving to a lot of potential co-founders
so I want to finish this section of my
talk with a goal for $0.50 this is this
is from when he was asked about vitamin
water I won't read it it's up there but
it's about the importance of thinking
about what customers want and thinking
about the demands of the market most
people don't do this most students
especially don't do this if you can just
do this one thing if you can just learn
to think about the market first you will
have a big leg up on most people
starting to startups and this is
something this is probably the thing
that we see wrong with Y Combinator apps
most frequently is that people have not
thought about the market first and what
people want first so for the next
section I'm going to talk about building
a great product and here again I'm going
to use a very broad definition of
product it includes customer support and
copyright explaining the product
anything involved in your customers
interaction with what you built from
them to build a really great company you
first have to turn a great idea into a
great product this is really hard but it
screws
important and fortunately it's pretty
fun although great products are always
new to the world and it's hard to give
you advice about what to build there are
enough commonalities that we can give
you a lot of advice about how to build
this one of the most important tasks for
a founder is to make sure that the
company builds a great product until
you've built a great product almost
nothing else matters when really
successful startup owners tell the story
of their early days it's almost always
sitting in front of the computer working
on that product or talking to their
customers that's pretty much all the
time they do very little else and you
should be very skeptical if your time
allocation is much different most other
problems that founders are trying to
solve raising money getting more press
hiring business development etc these
are significantly easier when you have a
great product it's really important to
take care of that first step one is to
build something that users love at YC we
tell founders to work on their product
talk to users exercise eating sleep and
very little else all the other stuff I
just mentioned PR conferences recruiting
advisors doing partnerships you should
ignore all of that and just build the
products and then get it as good as
possible by talking to your users your
job is to build something that users
love very few companies that go on to be
super successful get there without first
doing this a lot of good on paper
startups fail because they merely make
something that people like making
something that people want but only a
medium amount is a great way to fail and
not understand why you're failing so
these are the two jobs something that we
say oh I see a lot is it it's better to
build a small number it's better to
build something that a small number of
users love then a large number of users
like of course it'd be best to build
something that a small number of users
love but opportunities to do that for v1
are rare and they're usually not
available to startups so in practice you
end up choosing either the gray or the
orange you make something that a lot of
users like a little bit or something
that a small number of users like love a
lot and this is a very important piece
of advice build something the small
number of users love it's much easier to
expand from something that a small
number of people love doesn't mean it a
lot of people love then for something
that a lot of people like to a lot of
people love
if you get this right you can get a lot
of other things wrong if you don't get
this right you can get everything else
right and you'll probably still fail so
when you start on the startup this is
the only thing you need to care about
until it's working sure so you have a
choice in a start-up the best thing of
all world would be to build a product
that a lot of people really love in
practice you can't usually do that
because a big company if there's an
opportunity like that Google or Facebook
will do it so there's like a limit to
the area under the curve of what you can
build and you can either build something
that a lot of users like a little bit or
you can build some you to the small
number of users love a lot and like the
total amount of love is the same it's
just a question of how its distributed
and there's like this law of
conservation of how much happiness you
can put into the world with the first
product of a start-up and so startups
always struggle with which of those two
they should go and they seem equal right
because the area under the curve is the
same but we've seen this time and again
that they're not and that it's so much
easier to expand once you've got to mean
some people love you can expand that
somebody a lot of other people love but
if you only get ambivalence or sort of
like we can do is Yasim and then try to
expand that you'll never get up to a lot
of people loving it so the advice is
find a small group of users and make
them really love what you're doing that
makes them all right one way that you
know when this is working is that you'll
get growth by word of mouth if you make
something people love people will tell
their friends about it
this works for consumer products and
enterprise products as well when people
really love something they tell their
friends about it and you'll see you
organic growth if you find yourself
talking about how it's okay that you're
not growing because there's a big
partnership that's going to come save
you or something like that it's almost
always a sign of real trouble sales and
marketing are really important and we're
gonna have two classes on them later but
if you don't have some early organic
growth then your product probably isn't
good enough yet a great product is the
secret to long-term growth hacking you
should get that right before you worry
about anything else
it doesn't get easier to put off making
other product if you try to build a
growth machine
for you of a product that some people
really love you're almost certainly
going to waste your time
breakout companies almost always have a
product that's so good that it grows by
word of mouth over the long run great
products win don't worry about your
competitors raising a lot of money and
what they may do in the future they
probably aren't very good anyway
very few startups die from competition
most died because they themselves be
able to make something users love they
spend their time on other things
so worried about this above all else
another piece of advice to make some in
the users love start with something
simple it's much much easier to make a
great product if you have something
simple even if your eventual plan or
super complex and hopefully they are you
can almost always start with a smaller
subset of the problem and whatever you
think is the smallest and it's hard to
build a great product so you want to
start with as little surface area as
possible think about the really
successful companies and what they
started with think about products that
you really love they're generally
incredibly simple to use and especially
it gets started using the first version
of Facebook was almost comically simple
the first version of Google was just an
ugly web page with the text box and two
buttons that it returned the best
results and that's why users loved it
the iPhone is far simpler to use on any
smart phone that ever came before it and
it was the first one that people really
loved another reason it's simple is good
is because it forces you to do one thing
extremely well and you have to do that
to make something that people love the
word fanatical comes up again and again
when you listen to successful founders
talk about how they think about their
product founders talk about being
fanatical in the way they care about the
quality the small details fanatical and
getting the copy that they use to
explain the product just right in
fanatical in the way they think about
customer support in fact one thing that
correlates success among the YC
companies is the founders that hook up
de jeugd to their ticketing system so
even if they use your emails in the
middle of night when the founders are
asleep they still get a response in an
hour
companies actually do this many early
days these founders feel physical pain
when the product stocks and they want to
wake up and fix it they don't ship crap
and if they do they fix it very very
quickly and they definitely take some
level of fanaticism to build a great
product
you need some users to help with the
feedback cycle but the way to get those
users is manually you should go recruit
them by hand don't do things like buy
Google Ads in the early days to get
initial users you don't need very many
you just need ones that will give you
feedback every day and eventually love
your product so instead of trying to get
them on Google AdWords just find a few
people in the world that will be good
users recruitment by hand Ben Silbermann
when everyone thought Pinterest was a
joke
recruited the initial Pinterest users by
tagging up strangers and coffee shops he
really did he just walked around Palo
Alto and said will you please use my
product he also used to run around the
Apple store in Palo Alto and he would
like settle the browser's to the
Pinterest homepage real quick before
they caught it and kicked them out so
then when people walk in they're like oh
what is this this is an important
example of doing things that don't scale
if you haven't read Paul Graham's essay
on that topic you definitely should so
get users manually and remember that the
goal is to get a small group of them to
love you understand that group extremely
well get extremely close into them close
to them listen to them and you'll almost
always find out that they're very
willing to give you feedback even if
you're building the product for yourself
listen to outside users and they'll tell
you how to make a product they'll pay
for do whatever you need to make them
love you make them know you're doing
because they're also going to be the
advocates that help you get your next
users you want to build an engine in the
company that transforms feedback from
users into product decisions then get it
back in front of the users in a repeat
ask them what they like and what they
don't like and watch them use it ask
them what they pay for ask them if
they'd be really bummed if your company
went away ask them what would make them
recommend the product to their friends
and ask them if they've recommended if
any yet you should make this feedback
loop as tight as possible if your
product gets 10% better every week
that compounds really really quickly one
of the great advantages in start-up
software startups is just how short you
can make the feedback loop it can be
assured in hours and the best companies
usually have the tightest feedback loops
you should try to keep this going for
all of your company's life but it's
really important to me early days the
good news is that all this is doable
it's hard it takes a lot of effort but
there's no magic the plan is that we
straight forward and you will eventually
get to a great product
great founders don't put anyone between
themselves in their users the founders
of these companies do things like sales
and customer support themselves in the
early days it's critical to get this
loop embedded in the culture in fact the
specific problem that we always see with
Stanford startups for some reason is
that the students try and hire sales and
customer support people right away and
you got to do this yourself it's the
only way you really need to use metrics
to keep yourself honest on this it
really is true that the company will
build whatever the CEO decides to
measure if you're building the internet
service ignore things like solo
registrations don't talk about them
don't let anyone the company talk about
them and look at growth and active users
activity levels cohort retention revenue
and Net Promoter scores these things
that matter and then be brutally honest
if they're going the right direction
startups to live on growth it's the
indicator of a great product so this
about wraps up the overview on building
a great product I want to emphasize
again but if you don't get this right
nothing else we talked about in the
class will matter you can basically
ignore everything else that we talked
about until this is working well on the
positive side this is one of the most
fun parts of building a start-up so I'm
going to pause here I'll pick back up
with the rest of this on Thursday and
now we're going to have Dustin talk
about why you should start a startup
thank you for coming Desmond sure but
yes if Sam asked me to talk about why
you should start a startup there's a
bunch of reasons you might have and
there's a bunch of common reasons that
people have that I hear all the time for
for why you might start a startup it's
important to know like what reason is
yours because some of them only make
sense and in certain contexts some of
them will actually like lead you astray
you may have been misled by the way that
Hollywood or the press likes to
romanticize entrepreneurship so I want
to try and like illuminate you know some
of those potential fallacies so you guys
can make the decision in a clearer way
and then I'll talk about the reason I
like best for actually starting a
startup it's very related to a lot of
what Sam just talked about but
surprisingly I don't think it's the most
common reason usually people have one of
these other reasons or they just want to
start us you know start a company for
the sake of starting a company so the
four common reasons just to enumerate
them are glamorous you know you'll be
you'll get to be the boss
you'll have flexibility especially over
your schedule and you'll have the chance
to have you know bigger impact and make
more money than you might by joining a
later stage company so okay so you know
you guys are probably pretty familiar
with this concept when I wrote the
medium post which a lot of you guys were
out a year ago I felt like the story in
the press was a little more unbalanced
you know entrepreneurship just got
romanticized quite a bit you know movie
The Social Network came out had a lot of
sort of like bad aspects of you know
what it's like to be an entrepreneur but
mainly sort of painted this picture of
like there's a lot of partying and you
kind of move from like one brilliant
insight to another brilliant insight and
really made it you know seemed like this
like really cool thing to do and I think
the reality is just you know not quite
so glamorous there's sort of there's no
glee side to being an entrepreneur and
also just more importantly what would
you're actually spending your time on is
just a lot of hard work okay I mentioned
this but you're basically just sitting
at your desk heads down focus answering
customers customer support emails doing
sales figuring out hard engineering
problems so it's really important that
you kind of like going with with eyes
wide open and then also it's really
quite stressful this has been a popular
topic in the press lately
The Economist actually ran a story just
last week called like entrepreneurs
Anonymous and she was like a founder
kind of like hiding under his test and
talking about like founder depression
this is like a very real thing like you
know let's be real this if you start a
company it's going to be extremely hard
why is it so stressful so a couple
reasons one is you've got a lot of
responsibility so people in any kind of
career have fear failure kind of just
like a dominant part of the psychology
but when you're an entrepreneur your
fear of failure on behalf of yourself
and all of the people who decided to
follow you so that's really stressful in
some cases these people are depending on
you for their livelihood even when
that's not true they've decided to
devote those the best of your years of
their life to following you and so
you're responsible for the opportunity
cost of their time so that's a big deal
and you're always on call if something
comes up maybe not always at 3:00 in the
morning but for some startups that's
true but if something important comes up
you're going to deal with it that's kind
of
into the story of a matter if you're on
vacation doesn't matter if it's the
weekend you kind of always got to be on
the ball and always be in a in a place
mentally where you're prepared to deal
with those things and then a sort of
special example of that is uh or this
kind of stress is fundraising so it seen
from the social network this is us
partying and working at the same time
somebody's spraying champagne everywhere
you know so the social network spends a
lot of time kind of painting these
scenes Mark's not the scene the other
thing they'd spend all their time on is
kind of like painting him out to be a
huge jerk this computer yeah okay so
this is an actual scene from give this
is cool
awesome the work this work okay on the
PDF as well okay okay cool this is an
actual scene from Palo Alto spent a lot
of time this - kind of heads down in
focus
mark was still kind of a jerk sometimes
but in this more like fun lovable way
and not a like sociopathic scorned lover
way so this is him like signaling his
intention to you know just be focused
and keep working copy social so then
there's also the scene sort of
demonstrating the like brilliant insight
moment kind of like straight out of a
beautiful mind is literally stole that
scene so they'd like to paint it is you
just kind of like jump from one of these
moments to the other moment with like
parting in between but really reset that
table the whole time
so interestingly if you compare this the
other photo mark is in the exact same
position but he's wearing different
clothes this is definitely a different
day so cool so that's what that's what
it's actually like in person and I just
covered this bullet up here this is the
Economist articles talking about a
second ago so another form of stress is
just like unwanted media attention so
part of it being glamorous you get some
positive media attention sometimes it's
nice to be on like the cover of Time and
like be the person of the year it's
maybe a little less nice to be on the
cover of people with like one your
wedding photos depends who you are some
people would like that I'd really hate
it but when Valleywag like
you know analyzes your lecture and just
tears you apart like you definitely
don't want that nobody wants that and
then one thing I almost never hear
people talk about is you're just a lot
more committed so if you're an employee
of a start-up and you know things are
stressful not going well you're unhappy
you can just leave for a founder you can
leave but it's it's very uncool pretty
much a black eye on the rest of your
career
and so you really are committed you know
for 10 years if it's going well
probably more like 5 years if it's not
going well so three years to figure out
that it's not going well and then if you
find like a nice landing for your
company another two years at the
acquiring company and if you leave
before that again it's not only going to
harm your soul financially it's going to
harm all your employees you pretty much
don't so if you're lucky and you have a
bad startup idea you fail quickly but
most of the time it's not like that all
right moving right along so and I should
say I've had a lot of the stress in my
own life especially in the early years
of Facebook you know I just got really
unhealthy I wasn't exercising had a lot
of anxiety actually like through out my
back like almost every six months like
when I was like 21 22 which is like
pretty crazy and so if you do start a
company make you know be aware that
you're going to have to deal with this
and you have to actually manage it it's
actually like one of your core
responsibilities Ben Horowitz likes to
say like the number one role of a CEO is
managing your own psychology it's
absolutely true
make sure you do it so another reason
so people especially if they've already
had a job at another company you tend to
develop this narrative of like okay like
the people running this company or
idiots or making all these stupid
decisions they're spending their time in
in these stupid ways I'm going to start
a company and I'm going to do it better
I'm going to like set all the rules it's
a pretty attractive idea makes a lot of
sense if you've read my medium posts you
know it's coming you guys ii read this
quote
cool so this this really resonates with
me and one thing I'd point out is you
know reality of these decision decisions
is pretty new and nuanced the people you
thought were idiots probably weren't
idiots they probably just have like
really difficult decision in front of
them and people pulling them in multiple
directions so the most common thing I
have to spend my time on and focus my
energy on as a CEO is like the problems
that like other people are bringing to
me the other priorities that people
create and it's usually in the form of a
conflict people want to go in different
directions or like customers want
different things and like I might have
my own opinion about that but really the
game I'm playing is like who do I
disappoint the least and like just
trying to like navigate all these
difficult situations and even on a day
to day basis I might comment on Monday
and like have all these you know grand
plans for like how I'm going to improve
the company what I'm going to spend my
time on but then if like an important
employee is threatening to quit that's
what I'm spending my time on that's my
number one priority so a subset of your
the boss is you have flexibility you
have control over your own schedule this
really attractive idea so here's the
reality now there's a live-in quote so
this truly resonates with me as well
some of the reasons for this again
you're always on call so maybe you don't
intend to work all parts of the day but
you might not get to control which one's
your role model this is super important
so if you're an employee of a company
you might have some good weeks you might
have some bad weeks and weeks when
you're low energy maybe you want to take
a couple extra days off that's really
bad if you're an entrepreneur like your
team will really signal off what you're
bringing to the table so if you take
your foot off the gas so will they and
you're always working anyway so if
you're really passionate about an idea
it's just going to like pull you to keep
working on it
if you're working with great investors
you're working with great partners
they're going to want to be working
really hard they're going to want you to
be working really hard and again you're
going to want to work really hard so
some some companies like to tell the
story about you can have your cake and
you
- you can have like four day work weeks
maybe if you're a few ten Parris maybe
you can have a 12 hour workweek it's
really attractive idea and it does work
in a particular instance which is if you
want to like actually have a small
business or go after in each market then
your small business entrepreneur that
makes total sense but as soon as you get
past like two or three people you really
need to step it up and be full-time
committed cool so this is the big one
this is the one I hear the most
especially like candidates applying to
asana they tell me you know I'd really
like to work for much smaller company or
start my own because then I have a much
bigger slice of the pie I'll have much
more impact on how that company does and
I'll have more equity so I'll make more
money as well so let's examine when this
might be true so I'll explain these
tables they're little complex bullets
focused on the left first so these this
is just explaining Dropbox and Facebook
these are their current valuations and
this is how much money you might make as
employee number 100 coming into these
companies especially if you're like an
experienced engineer like you have like
five years of industry experience you're
pretty likely to have an offer that's
around 10 basis points so if you join
Dropbox a couple years ago the upside
you'd have already walked in is about 10
million plenty more growth from there if
you leave in the company if you join
Facebook a couple years into its
existence you made 200 million dollars
this is a huge number and if you even if
you join Facebook is employee number
1,000 so you joined it like 2009 you
still made twenty million dollars that's
a giant number and that's how you should
be benchmarking when you're thinking
about what might I make is an
entrepreneur so moving over to the table
on the right these are too theoretical
companies you might start so uber for
Pet Sitting pretty good idea if you're
if you're really well suited to this you
might have a really good shot at
building a hundred million dollar
company and then your share of that
company is pretty likely to be about 10
percent this certainly fluctuates some
boundaries have a lot more than that
some have a lot less but after multiple
rounds of dilution
multiple rounds of option table option
pool creation you're pretty likely to
end up about here if you have more than
this
I'd recommend Sam's post on like the
equity split between founders and
employees you probably should be giving
out more and then but so basically if
you're extremely confident about filling
$100,000,000 business which is a big ask
it should go without saying that you
should have a lot more confidence in
facebook in 2009 or Dropbox in 2014 then
you might for a startup that doesn't
even exist yet
then this is worth doing so if you have
a hundred million dollar idea and you're
pretty confident you get execute it I
would consider that if you think you're
the right entrepreneur to build uber
uber for space travel that's a really
huge idea two billion dollar idea you're
actually gonna have a pretty good return
for that you should definitely do that
this is also only the value after four
years and this idea probably has legs so
definitely go after that if you're
thinking of building that you probably
shouldn't even be in this class right
now just go and go and build that
company um so why is this financial
reward and impact I really think that
financial rewards very strongly
correlated with the impact you have on
the world if you don't believe that
let's talk through some specific
examples and not think about the equity
at all so why my joining late stage
company actually provide you a lot of
impact you get this force multiplier
they have an existing massive user base
it's Facebook the billion users or
Google of civilian users they have
existing infrastructure you get to build
on that's also increasingly true for new
startups thanks to like AWS and all
these like awesome independent service
providers but you usually get some micro
proprietary technology and Saul
maintained for you pretty great place to
start and you get to work with a team
and they'll help you just leverage your
idea into something great so a couple
specific examples
Brett Taylor came in to employee around
or came into Google as around employee
number 1500 and he invented Google Maps
this is a product you guys probably use
every day I used it to get here and it's
used by hundreds millions of people all
around the world didn't need to start a
company to do that did happen to get a
big financial reward but the point is
yet match them
a co-founder Justin Rosenstein joined
Google a little later after Brett he was
a p.m. there and just as a side project
he ended up prototyping chat with you
which used to be a standalone app as
integrated into Gmail like you see it an
upper right there and before he did that
like people didn't even think you could
do chat over Ajax or chat in the browser
at all and he just kind of like
demonstrated it and showed it to his
team and they made it happen again this
is this is probably a product most of
you used maybe everyday and then perhaps
even more impressively shortly after
that er left he became employee round
number 250 at Facebook and he led a
hackathon project along with people like
Andrew Bosworth and women to create the
like button so this was one of the most
popular elements anywhere on the web
totally changes how people use it and
again didn't need to start a company to
do it and almost certainly would have
failed if he had tried because you
really needed the distribution of
Facebook to make it work so important to
keep in mind the context for what kind
of company you're trying to start and
like where will you actually be able to
make it happen so what's the best reason
so Sam are you talked about this a
little bit but basically you can't not
do it you're super passionate about this
idea you're the right person to do it
you've got to make it happen so how does
this break down we're getting close to
here am i doing on time oh cool sweet
perfect so this this is sort of like a
wordplay you can't not do it in two ways
one is you're so passionate about it
that you just like you have to do it
you're going to do it anyway and this is
really important because you'll need
that passion to get through all of those
like hard parts of being an entrepreneur
that we talked about earlier you'll also
need it to effectively recruit
candidates can smell when you don't have
passion and they're enough entrepreneurs
out there who do have passion that they
may as well work for one of those so
this is sort of like table stakes for
being an entrepreneur your subconscious
can also tell when you don't have
passion and that'll be a huge problem
and then so the other way to interpret
this is the world needs you to do it so
this is sort of validation that the idea
is important it's going to make the
world better the world needs it if it's
not
if it's not something the world needs go
do something the world needs Yukons
really valuable there are plenty of good
ideas out there maybe it's not one of
your own maybe it's an existing company
but you may as well work on something
that's going to be good and then the
second way to interpret this is the
world needs you to do it you're actually
well suited to this problem in some way
if this isn't true it may be a sign that
your time is better spent somewhere else
but also just best-case scenario if this
isn't true you out-compete the team for
which it is true and you just end up
with like a suboptimal outcome for the
world that doesn't feel very good so
drawing this back to my own experience
at asana you know Justin and I were kind
of like reluctant entrepreneurs before
we founded a sauna so we were working at
Facebook we're already working on a
great problem and we would basically
work all day long on our normal projects
and then at night we would keep working
on this internal task manager that was
used internally at the company and was
just because we were like so passionate
about the idea it was so clearly
valuable that we couldn't do anything
else and at some point we had to have
the hard conversation of like okay well
what does it mean if we don't actually
start this company we were able to see
the impact was having on Facebook we
were pretty convinced it could be really
valuable for the world we were also
pretty convinced nobody else was going
to build it the problem had been around
a long time and you just kept seeing
sort of incremental solutions to it so
if we didn't go out with the one that we
thought was best we thought there'd be a
lot of value left on the table and yeah
so we just couldn't couldn't stop
working on it and literally the idea was
like beating itself out of our chest
like forcing itself into the world and I
think that's the feeling you should
really be looking for when you start a
company that's when you know you have
the right idea so I'll go ahead and stop
there I'll put some recommended books up
here but we'll narrate them and
investing across yes thank you
[Applause]
you have questions for him and see you
Thursday thank you